some of the small details in Oppenheimer
are added for dramatic effects but a
surprising percentage of them are pulled
straight from the history books in
addition to the encounter where
Oppenheimer attempts to poison his
instructor at Cambridge his meeting with
Harry S Truman is pretty accurate
according to the Oppenheimer biography
American Prometheus Oppenheimer did
confess to feeling like he had bad blood
on his hands to Truman and the president
did brush him off like he does in the
film drawing the Trinity test the movie
shows Nobel Prize winner Richard Feynman
watching the explosion without
protective glasses as he claims that the
windshield of his truck will protect him
this too is true to life according to
feynman's own account in his
autobiography additionally a lot of
lines in the movie were actually spoken
by the actual people for instance in his
last Alamo speech Oppenheimer did say
that he regretted that the bomb couldn't
have been used on the Nazis though it
certainly makes some tweaks Oppenheimer
has a lot of great historical details
that really add to the effect